[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain a south korean sports
comedy film called champion spoilers
ahead watch out and take care
the story surrounds a former korean arm
wrestler named mark he currently works
as a bouncer in a club in america one
evening at work he is approached by his
old associate kim who urges him to
compete in an arm wrestling match mark
is not interested but kim doesn't give
up and eventually persuades him they go
to the other side of the club where
people are enjoying betting on matches
the guy mark is competing against has
won for the entire night making mark the
underdog even though the other guy is
clearly going to be more tired no one
wants to bet on someone like him which
turns out to be an advantage for kim the
match starts and mark proves why he used
to be a professional arm wrestler the
opponent breaks a lot of sweat but
cannot move mark's hand by an inch
without even trying mark wins the game
which makes kim a bucket full of money
conflict arises when the guy who lost
refuses to accept defeat he hits kim
which eventually causes a fight between
mark and a bunch of customers because of
the fight he is kicked out of the job a
week later he gets another job as a
security guard in a grocery store he
makes a decent living and is content
with his life except sometimes he misses
home then one day he gets a call from
kim asking him to come to korea there is
an arm wrestling tournament starting in
seoul the winner of which will get to
compete at the international level mark
stares at his old medals for a long time
before deciding to take the biggest risk
in his life upon landing in seoul kim
comes to pick him up they go to a
restaurant and talk about business over
a meal kim wants to be mark's agent and
take care of the business side of his
profession he wishes mark well but is
planning to go into the betting business
to make more money for this he will have
to exploit mark's skill for the
remainder of the day the duo takes a
tour of seoul at one of the destinations
some girls mistake mark for a tourist
attraction and take pictures with him
after living in america for many years
mark's korean tongue is shaky which
leads him to many awkward conversations
at night they go to a club but mark
stands in the corner the entire time
subconsciously working as a bouncer
again on their way to the hotel kim
inquires if he has ever wanted to find
out where his biological mother is it
turns out that mark was given up for
adoption as a child he says that he has
no interest in meeting anyone since all
of it is in the past kim then drops him
at the place he is staying for the night
which happens to be a love hotel mark
experiences a vibrating waterbed for the
first time but what really catches his
attention is a gift box it is from kim
and has a phone inside on checking he
finds the address of his biological
mother on it somewhere else kim
approaches a millionaire loan shark
named you and asks him to sponsor mark
initially he is hung upside down for
talking to you without permission but
upon looking at a video of mark the
gangster agrees to sponsor him his only
condition is that mark will have to win
and lose as ordered the next morning
mark follows the map on his phone and
makes it to an address before knocking
on the door two kids approach him his
build makes them believe he is a beast
so to avoid scaring them he walks away
the children tell their mother sue me
about the strange guy standing in front
of their house the family spies on mark
through the window and watches him walk
away sue me owns a thrift store that is
not doing well she owes a lot of money
to the gangster you who troubles her
every chance he gets that day at work
she notices mark and you walking into a
club in the mall kim has brought mark to
introduce him to the sponsors and
showcase his skills there we are also
introduced to a wealthy spoiled
youngster named chang he is u's partner
and the one who spends the most money on
bets mark proves his worth by defeating
a bulky man from the navy because of the
win he and kim are given a luxury room
in a five-star hotel kim gets a text
from you that says mark should win the
first match tomorrow but lose the second
one he is afraid that mark won't agree
to the conditions they go out for dinner
and kim brings up the topic of losing
the second match to his surprise mark
agrees to do it without a fuss the
following morning we see sumi getting
her kids ready for school the eldest ju
hyung is worried that the big man will
come to the house again sumi suspects
that mark is someone she knows after the
kids leave for school she brings out old
pictures and finds one with little mark
and his mother outside the kids bump
into him again the youngest jun hee is
excited but joo hyung threatens to call
the police if he sees mark again in the
next scene we are introduced to korea's
number one arm wrestling champion named
combo yuu invites him to the club that
evening to evaluate mark's skill he
doesn't want to bet money recklessly
until a professional gives him the green
light that mark is actually trustworthy
in the evening everyone gathers at the
club mark goes against a seven foot
giant in the first match he wins with
great effort impressing even korea's
very own champion sue me is also in the
audience watching mark during the break
you tries touching her inappropriately
declaring that he owns her because of
the money she owes him mark sees this
take place and is not happy about it
when the second match starts he
deliberately wins to spite you when you
tries to assert his ownership he is
pushed aside kim loses his mind trying
to please the boss and mark at the same
time he realizes that sue me is the
reason mark betrayed him in a fit of
rage he goes to her to inquire about her
relationship with mark at the same time
yu arrives and starts assaulting kim
mark intervenes causing a fight to start
between all of you's people and him
alone during the fight sumi asks you to
stop his men only to be pushed to the
ground the commotion halts when the
police arrest mark and kim they need
mark's identification for him to be let
free but he has lost his bag and
passport in the previous fight the
policeman and mark go against each other
in a match and he proves that he is
actually an arm wrestler still the man
refuses to let him go without proper
identification right then sumi comes to
the police station with her kids she has
found his passport and has a picture of
him and his mother which proves his
identity it is then revealed that sumi
is mark's stepsister and their mother
died a year ago mark is heartbroken to
hear the news and doesn't know how to
process it the family invites mark and
kim to stay in their house for a few
days the kids love him because of his
unique personality little june he likes
to snuggle with mark while jun hyung
starts talking to him more often outside
the house a bunch of teens are smoking
refusing to go even when sumi asks them
to but when mark comes into their view
they apologize and run away in an
instant the next day used people come to
collect money from sue me and threaten
her at the same time mark is about to
leave with his belongings not wanting to
be a burden to the family he sends the
loan sharks away but the thugs make him
realize that he should stay with his
family to protect them for the next few
days they have a lot of fun together
they go to buffets eat together play
collectively and live like a happy
family until now it was difficult for
sumi to handle a business and two kids
on her own her house is filled with
unorganized clothes from her business
one day she returns home to see that it
has all been cleaned mark also takes
care of the children so she can focus on
work meanwhile kim is in trouble because
of a shortage of money upon seeing mark
with the kids he gets an idea and calls
a friend in a broadcasting company he
wants to document mark's life to gain
people's sympathy alongside some money
mark is skeptical but agrees to do it
anyway in the following scene we see
mark and the family going on an outing
they come across korea's wrestling
champion combo competing with
challengers for a charity event mark
challenges him and wins the game
surprising everyone a few weeks later
the story about his harsh past adoption
and struggles in wrestling is made into
a documentary and televised the show
becomes an instant success and makes
them a decent amount of money the
children start looking up to their uncle
even more one day on their way to the
school they overhear a woman badmouthing
mark in retaliation jun hee declares
that her uncle is a champion and makes
him promise that he will win the
national championship for her in the
following scene we are introduced to
kim's father who is old but works very
hard to make a living the only reason
why kim is adamant about making more
money is that he wants to give his
father the best life one where he
doesn't have to work anymore on
returning home that day jun hyung calls
mark and shows him the emails that his
mother used to write every day mark
finds out that his mother's biggest
regret in life was giving him up for
adoption throughout her life she wrote
several emails to an address that wasn't
his in the emails she described how hard
life was when he was with her she
couldn't afford to feed him and wanted
him to have a better life even on her
deathbed all she wished was to meet him
and say sorry mark also finds out that
sumi is not his stepsister his mother
took her in when she was a kid after her
parents passed away the news shocks mark
making him furious at sue me for never
telling him the truth in the following
scene the family drives to mark's
mother's grave while on the trip he
calls sumi out for her lies mark has
decided to return to america leaving
them behind for good kim tries to stop
him since he hasn't taken part in the
tournament yet and it is in a week
however a frustrated mark accuses him of
using his friend for money and leaves in
the following montage we see korea's
champion combo practicing for the
championship the gangster you has also
hired a beast named kane he used to be a
ruthless arm wrestler famous for
breaking every single arm he played
against a few years ago he was arrested
for using pills to over perform in games
he also practices his best ready to get
back in the game then the day of the
tournament finally arrives the kids are
home alone when they notice that they
forgot to return the medal to mark using
this excuse they board a bus and make
their way to the arena to watch him
wrestle a while later sumi gets a call
from her friend at the arena and has to
run to get her children the competition
starts and kane mark and combo are put
in three different groups they dominate
the matches of their respective groups
and make it to the semi-finals a
ruthless cane hurts many of his
opponents and goes to the final the
millionaire investor chang and his
people have bet all their money on kane
upon seeing how good mark is performing
they are scared to lose all the money
hence chang orders you to do everything
he can to ensure their player wins you
in turn offers kim 200 000 for him to
convince mark to lose in the semi-finals
against combo kim accepts the money and
goes to tell his friend but mark refuses
to seal the deal the money will pay off
all their debts and fulfill their life
wishes but still it is not worth the
promise mark made to june he hence he
wrestles combo in an intense match and
wins in the end during the break between
matches you catches kim and proceeds to
beat him however the thugs are stopped
by mark he pushes the gangster to the
floor and saves his friend kim forgets
about the money and asks him to win at
any cost the final match starts and
everyone holds their breath to watch it
kane plays foul and deliberately makes
their hands slip he also pulls on mark's
thumb very hard making him slower with
every pause the ball seems to fall in
kane's cord but just then from the side
of his eyes mark sees the children
rooting for him with renewed interest to
prove his worth to them mark pushes
kane's hand at once and defeats him in
the last scene mark tells his mother
that he loves her on television he
cannot help but cry at the thought of
her suffering so much the movie ends as
everyone celebrates the win subscribe
for more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching